for dinner at a 1940s downtown diner
sound sounds really good to me so and
you can do that on may 6th and 7th and
you can enjoy it thanks to winnie and
ethel's downtown diner pop-up so let's
welcome co-owner mallory got to the show
you and your and chef aaron yes you guys
are a dynamic duo we are you've come
together and brought this to life we are
and it might be confusing for people
watching when you hear dynamic duo it's
not rocky we love her but we're not
going to put her to work jeff aaron's
actually hard at work right now which is
why he's not with us but we are
finalists in the great las vegas coffee
shop giveaway oh my god we're really
excited absolutely and and mind you um
you don't want me to be the
chef you don't want me to be the chef
either okay
we're in the same boat but we're going
to drink great shout outs
that's right that's right we love you we
love you chef aaron okay so let's talk
about you know first and foremost i have
to know who is
winnie and ethel so we are winning yes
so winnie is um chef aaron's grandma and
ethel is my great grandma
and one of your kind staff asked us if
they were going to join us today and
unfortunately no
however we do have a lot of their
recipes and all that warmth and love
that each of us got in their respective
kitchens growing up that's what we're
bringing to the diner club that's
beautiful you're this is their legacy
that's exactly right right that's
exactly so then let's talk about what's
on the menu all right so from these
classic grandmas yeah so chef aaron has
done a fantastic job everything that
he's put together whether it's from the
grandmas or not is all centered around
that 1940s feel simple classic food that
people would have enjoyed when they when
they pulled up to the countertop uh what
almost 80 years ago now
what we've got today are some of our
malted milk pancakes
that same delicious ingredient you get
in a malted milk shake in pancakes i
know i know can i just i know and it's
got brown butter maple syrup so
everything's got a little bit of a
delightful twist and then on top of it
we've got this fantastic homemade
chocolate pudding with very very lightly
whipped cream it's all done by hand from
really good high quality ingredients
it's simple stuff but when you do it
right just like the grandmas did it
doesn't have to be complex to be
fantastic i completely understand that
okay so we have about 30 seconds let's
make it but why we while we make it tell
everybody how they can help you win this
competition all right so i'm going to
have you do a dollop of whipped cream on
top of one of those right there and then
follow it with sprinkles if you want to
come out and try this food and you want
to help us make winnie and ethel's
downtown diner a reality in the las
vegas community we'd love for you to
stop by our pop-up it's next friday may
6 and saturday may 7th from noon to 8
p.m at the vegas test kitchen and you
can rsvp on our instagram page at winnie
and ethel's that was beautiful thank you
ready to take a bite
[Music]
oh
yeah wow this is my childhood that says
it all right there that amazingly says
it all it doesn't take a lot to be great
wow thank you mallory my pleasure
congratulations in advance thank you so
much